[موسيقى]
الاستخبارات الامريكيه تكشف عن مذبحه
مروعه للاوكرانيين راح ضحيتها اكثر من
عشره الاف اوكرانيه والمانيا توجه تهما من
العيار الثقيل للقياده الاوكرانيه وقوتك
[موسيقى]
الغرب قرروا محاربه روسيا حتى اخر جندي
اوكراني
مليارات الغرب لا تكفي نصف احتياجاتنا فهل
من مزيد وغواصه الموت الروسيه تدخل حلبه
الحرب الاوكرانيه يرسل كبيره مستشاريه الى
السعوديه فما الذي يجري خلف الستار
السياسي وارض السوداني وسمائها تشتعلان من
جديد
مجزره القرن الاوكرانيه لكل حرب حصاد ولكن
الحصاد ياتي في النهايه وما زرعه الغرب في
اوكرانيا حصده الدب الروسي سريعا او هكذا
يقولها
بان قواته في اوكرانيا دمرت 245 دبابه
ونحو
6078 عربه مصفحه من انواع مختلفه ولكن
مهلا يا هؤلاء كما ضامن الوقت منذ استلام
هذه الدبابات في الحقيقه انتم تعلمون انه
ليس بالوقت الطويل ولكن الثلث تلك
الدبابات
ذهبت ادراج الرياح وفق الرئاسه الروسيه
وكما تشاهدون في المصدر هو يتحدث عن
الاعداد المذكوره وليس ذلك فحسب بل ان اهم
اجهزه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ايضا اصبح
هدفا لقوات بوتين حيث اكد المتحدث باسم
استخبارات وزاره الدفاع الاوكراني ان
المقر الرئيسي للاستخبارات في العاصمه
يتعرض لهجوم الا انه لا يزال يعمل ولم
يتوقف ولا حتى لمده ساعه ليصرح المحلل
السابق بوكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه
بان القوات الاوكرانيه تكبدت خسائر فادحه
وتعرضت لمذبحه مروعه للغايه اثناء هجومها
المضاد الفاشل لان اكثر من عشره الاف جندي
اوكراني قتلوا حتى دون اختراق خط الدفاع
الاول وفق قول لاري وهنا امامكم المصدر من
الموقع الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه والذي نقل
الخبر عن وكاله نوفوستي فنحن لا نزكي اي
اعداد الا عن طريق مصادر موثوقه المصائب
لا تاتي فرادى على كييف وهنا وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه الى
الاوروبي في قولها ان اوكرانيا مطالبه
بالقضاء على الفساد المناجي في مؤسساتها
بشكل تام حتى تتمكن من الانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي ليتساءل المحللون اذا كانت
اوكرانيا لم تستطع مواجهه فساد مؤسساتها
قبل الحرب فهل ستقدر على ذلك بعدها ليعود
الرئيس الروسي مره اخرى ويقول ان اوكرانيا
لا تزال مدججه بالمعدات والاسلحه الا ان
احتياطيه تعبئه البشريه له حدود واضاف
بوتين نحلفاء اوكرانيا الغربيين على ما
يبدو قرار حقا محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا فيما اعلن وزير الدفاع
الروسيسركي ان القوات الاوكرانيه تعمل
حاليا على اعاده ترتيب صفوفها وذلك بعد
الخسائر الفادحه خلال 16 يوما الماضيه
واردف بالقول انما تم تسليمه من اسلحه الى
كييف وسيتم تسليمه مستقبلا لن يؤثر على
مسار العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا فهل
وصلت الرساله الروسيه للغرب لا يبدو انها
وصلت وهنا يعلن
رئيس سكارينش ان بلاده قدمت لاوكرانيا كل
ما بحوزتها من صواريخ كما تنوي تقديم جميع
الطائرات المروحيه المتاحه لدي قريبا
ليعلن وزير الدفاع
عن تخصيص بلاده حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده
لاوكرانيا بما يلبي احتياجات القوات
الاوكرانيه لكنه اوضح انها تراعي في الوقت
نفسه قدرات بلغاريا العسكريه فكم تبلغ
قدراتكم العسكريه يا هذا اذا ومن
المساعدات الغربيه ننتقل الى الحرب
الاوكرانيه ذاتها وهنا عادت كييف بهوايتها
في تفجير وضرب الجسور كما تقول موسكو حيث
اعلن القائم باعمال حاكم مقاطعه خرسون
فلاديميرالدو ان القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفت الجسور التي تربط بين مقاطعه
خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم الروسيتين ومن هذه
الجسور جسر الذي يعد اهم الطرق لنقل
المعدات والاليات من في جزيره القرم الى
منطقه زبروجها كما انه يعتبر الرابط بين
ريفي منطقه خرسون والقرم هناك توعد الجيش
الاوكراني بشل مزيد من الهجمات ضد الجسور
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها القوات
الروسيه وكما هو معتاد لا تاتي الاخبار من
رؤوسنا وها هو المصدر امامكم القوات
الاوكرانيه تستهدف جسرا استراتيجيا يربط
بين خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم وتاتي هذه
الضربه في وقت تنفذ فيه القوات الاوكرانيه
عمليه هجوميه منذ مطلعي يونيو على العديد
من الجبهات خصوصا في الجنوب
لترد موسكو بالاعلان ان قوتها الفضائيه
دمرت بضربات صاروخيه عاليه الدقه مخزنا
كبيرا للاسلحه والذخائر الغربيه وذلك بعد
ان تسلمت مؤخرا دفعه جديده من عتاد النيتو
ودعمك كما طردت انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه
طائره مسيره الاوكرانيه ليعلن البنك
الدولي
فئه لاوكرانيا بقيمه تفوق مليارا و750
مليون دولار وهناك اعلنت وزاره ماليه
الاوكرانيه
تلقييف مساعدات بلغت نحو 20 مليار دولار
من شركائها منذ بدايه العام الجاري لكن
وزير الماليه الاوكراني
بحاجه الى 110 مليارات دولار كمساعدات حتى
عام 2027 ولن تغطي الخمسون مليار يورو
التي وعد بها الاتحاد الاوروبي نصف
احتياجات البلاد اي ان كييف لا تكتفي
وتقول هل من مزيد وبما ان الغرب لا يتوقف
عن ضخ الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا ها هي موسكو
تقول كفى للسلاح الغربي حيث اعلن الادمرال
نيكولاي ادمنوفا القائد العام للقوات
البحريه الروسيه
[موسيقى]
التي تحمل التربيدات النوويه المائيه
المسيره من طراز البوسيدون ستنضم الخدمه
في القوات البحريه الروسيه خلال العام
الحالي لمواجهه التهديدات الغربيه الرد
جاء من اوكرانيا ولكنه كان خجولا هذه
المره حيث اطلق الجيش الاوكراني الصواريخ
من نوع جراد نحو مواقع روسيه قرب بخموت
وتاتي هذه الخطوه في اطار التصعيد العسكري
المستمر بين الجانبين في المنطقه وبين هذا
وذاك اعلن نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
الان حل لمكرون وامثاله في قمه بريكس في
جنوب افريقيا لانها من الدول غير صديقه
الاحداث والتطورات نقل موقع اكسيوس عن
مصادره ان كبيره مستشاري الرئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن للطاقه
سيزر السعوديه هذا الاسبوع ليبحث مع
المسؤولين السعوديين سبل التطبيع بين تل
ابيب والرياضه هل ستطبع قبله المسلمين مع
اسرائيل
وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليا تعقب عمليه القصف الجوي في
جنين ان القوات الاسرائيليه ستتخذ نهجا
هجوميا وستستخدم كل الوسائل المتاحه له
فيما تم الاعلان عن اصابه نحو 170
فلسطينيه بحالات اختناق في عمليه مداهمه
اسرائيليه في نابلس والان الى التطورات في
السودان وبعد يومين على انتهاء الهدنه
تجدد القصف والاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في الخرطوم وام درمان وحلق
الطائرات حربيه في العاصمه الخرطوم
بالتزامن مع اطلاق نار جنوب غربي ام درمان
والقصف المدفعي وقصف الصواريخ الموجهه
يعود للواجهه من جديد
[موسيقى]